so the point of diversity equity and
inclusion as you often heard is to wind
up with the leadership class that quote
looks like America and we think you
should hire in the basis of Merit
but that's kind of an appealing idea the
people who run the country should look
like the country that's not what it's
about at all
because no Administration has ever
looked less like America just by the
numbers than the Biden Administration
it's not about making the administration
look like Americans but discriminated
against certain classes of people who
don't vote for them period
and now it's provable Jeremy Carl at the
Claremont Institute just ran the numbers
and this is in the Judiciary he found
that out of 97 federal judges confirmed
under Joe Biden total number of white
men
five
22 are black women
so this is race-based hiring it's
illegal but it's also not about looking
like America it's about punishing people
and it's also incidentally or maybe not
incidentally producing nominees for
federal judgeships who know nothing
about the Constitution like this person
judge on the far end
uh tell me what article 5 of The
Constitution does
Article 5 is not coming to mind at the
moment okay how about article two
neither is article two
she doesn't know what's in the
Constitution but she's going to be a
federal judge whose job it is to
interpret the law against the
Constitution okay
so degrading horse Cooper is the
co-chairman of project 21 he's also a
lawyer who knows what's in the
Constitution Horace thanks so much for
coming on by the way I'm not a lawyer
not even as I don't have a successful
background in Academia and I knew what
those were so like that's pretty bad
right why is this not on the front page
of the New York Times
well it should have been Tucker you know
I actually taught an article one course
all about the legislative process at uh
George Mason University and it's
important that people understand what
the options what the authorities what
the powers that our Founders granted our
Congress our our federal legislature and
we had an entire course focused on that
but George Mason like other good schools
wants quality graduates we want talented
graduates and we're interested in seeing
to it that the people who leave with a
degree are masters of the topic what
we're seeing from the Biden
Administration and which is what we're
seeing generally
from the Progressive Movement is this
idea that we just need need to reshape
the Judiciary in a way under color
I use that term in a duplicative way
by pretending that we're making the
courts look more like America but the
truth of the matter is we're finding
people they aren't talented they aren't
highly skilled but they know Progressive
Vision just like the back of their hand
that's the ultimate goal of what's
Happening Here not excellence and
America suffers Corporation suffers
defendants suffer
well it is just so unbelievably
degrading I think for the whole country
it's the opposite of excellence and I
appreciate your saying so horoscope
great seats sorry go ahead
I was just going to say we set up this
independent
Judiciary as a way for every American
instead of self-help which is the nasty
way of saying I'm not going to rely on
the legal or the justice system we set
up our Founders set up this independent
Judiciary so that we can get people to
voluntarily agree to bring their
disputes there I don't want the
cardiologist to be chosen by his color I
don't want the pilot to be chosen by his
race and I don't want the Judiciary to
be chosen that way we need excellence
and this Administration doesn't want
that amen great decision thank you horse
thank you
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight